for all of you mother lovers out there
who've been following us for over 16
years we thank you very very much we
wanted to do something extremely special
a big makeover okay we're going to start
losing some weight and becoming women
just kidding what we wanted to do is a
major new reveal for you guys and 2024
2024 brand new this whole office right
here we did a lot of memories together
but it's going to be completely brand
new and no one's seen it yet so these
were the first reactions of everybody
coming in and going oh my God this is
what it's going to be like from this
point on Ryan and Joe worked on
revamping the JK office and I have yet
to see it so I'm just recording my
reaction and I can already see little
glimpses I'm going to close my
eyes okay now I'm inside
whoa ho holy [__] we just got here so
let's
go
oh oh my
gosh things are hella
different
damn this place is [__]
sick holy [__] [__] this is crazy
you're a [__] genius bro what the
[__] [__]
Bro dude I'm [__] speechless oh Uncle
Sam and Uncle chin what the [__] what
and and when we kick the walls they put
F this is when we kicked the
walls
wow check got our new set dude it's
pretty cool man welcome what the [__]
bro what the [__] I like how he said
what the [__] to just that corner this
corner is crazy
hello welcome to the new office welcome
sir holy
[__] right holy [__] it actually looks
cool in
here oh my God all right apparently
there's a brand new office set up at the
JK office I missed the Reveal video
yesterday so I'm coming in seeing it for
the first time
today come here open it I got no
hands check out the new office dude
that's have no hands yeah I got no hands
what's up man hey check out the new
office oh [__] this is obviously my
corner represents me the most holy
[__] oh wait why am I locking it oh my
and the chairs just [__] crazy huh
oh bro this is your new home it's your
new home man we got chairs we got new
chairs what the [__] bro we have a whole
what is this what do you call this this
backarat we got backarat bat roulette
yeah that's what I said this was meant
to be your Jiu-Jitsu Podium yeah really
it's to be a second place Podium oh my
God so
cool you got to see you got to see your
Colts room in the back get the [__] out
of here yeah Ser your kitchenette oh my
God you guys were the best dude this is
awesome Anthony did this all by
himself dude it look oh my gosh is this
place [__] incredible it's almost
like we're proud of this place we are
proud bro what are you talking about oh
my gosh it's kab B so you have free
promo this is I think like 40 bucks a
month that you have to pay at Bas for
dude dude bro you're amazing isn't he
amazing this is [__] incredible
doesn't make sense this is like a cool
spot
yeah like we can take chicks here here
we can actually take women
here wow this is so slick we're finally
going to get laid dude finally going to
get L hey
y this is The Man Behind the plan he
made this happen we've been talking
about it for oh smack yeah me and smack
me and smack she's actually the real
Mastermind she's the real man behind the
plan and AIS he carried some stuff yeah
a 2x4s yeah so it took about no Anthony
though an didn't do [__] but Ryan is the
man behind this wonderful wonderful
place yeah yeah plus smack of course but
there are two two PS in the Pod and I
just want to say thank you so [__]
much oh it's been so many years that
we've been living in garbage you know in
filth in filth with [__] allergy
attacks every five minutes with red eyes
all day I'll tell you this when we had
the old office in Downtown LA we spent a
home worth we built a house basically it
was like seven it was 700 Grand we
[__] threw that in the toilet I wish
we knew you back then gave that all to
you yeah so this R this whole place uh
came together a little bit over $3,000
because he's [__] genius no one else
can do that kind of are you serious tell
us to [__] spend it it'll be a
million dollar of course we already had
a lot of the most expensive stuff we
already owned that and then a lot of the
things are secondhand we originally were
talking about how we're going to do the
place up I sent Bart and Joe this this
sketch which you are going to see and um
it was like a sketch of roughly of what
the Place could be with that was the
part that my first uh going like wow
this is very impressive is the fact that
Ryan even has like a sketch or a PL like
blueprints to show us I was like dude
this guy already does things way better
than Anthony has ever
done it took about maybe three or four
days of of just moving things in and
taking things out which was like the
most timec consuming thing because there
was so much stuff in here we to move
everything out you crazy move it back in
that's after I already did a preliminary
and threw out like I know three
truckloads worth of [__] yeah we threw a
lot of stuff out man but yeah let's go
over some of it this was 15 years worth
of junk collecting how was your
allergies during I think the most
important thing when building it was we
just wanted to make sure that the JK
fans were like represented in the build
so they could see little details that
they were the ones that came up with
whether it was in the comments or in the
DMS the inside jokes are very like
representative of the audience of this
era M's very thoughtful and uh and I
know that like originally this place was
built with a lot of love back in the day
like there's a whole video of it I think
on the channel like way back when you
but all the love leaked
out yes and Ryan filled it back up with
love so we want to want to restore that
like feeling of like freshness and like
that we really care about it so let's
start with this this was probably one of
the biggest things this is now the James
Rulo Memorial clock shout out to James
Rulo James Rulo most people don't even
see this cuz it's not on camera but
that's our timer which tells Bart when
to get up and take a [__] I don't take
Joe takes a [__] I turn off the cameras
early that's true that that clock used
to sit on two apple boxes but now at
least it's mounted to the Wallock over
every takes someone will walk by and
knock over yeah and since you can
already see these These are the holes
that were made from like I guess Bart
David I don't know who else made just me
and Joe shut the fu what the
hell oh my God look at this uh that's
Kinder bag noodles in the in the hole
where it belongs uh yeah so rather than
fix the holes we wanted to preserve it
by just framing them and just kind of
immortalizing them exactly as is that's
a small one yeah that's baby one I think
Gio did that with a spear this is Bart
and Nick's area basically wait wait
stand in stand right there real quick
hey where'd you go oh wow really good
yeah so we wanted to fill it with uh
with stuff that's very representative
bar Bart did basically his own thing and
put all his own equipment on here which
is the real [__] that you used right
yeah well you you set it up really nice
and I was like oh cool can I replace
some things you're like yeah and I just
replaced a couple things with like a lot
of it is actually from my time and
service thatu like 15 20 years old cuz
it's
stolen cuz it all fell it all fell off
the truck
yeah fake grass look yeah we put some
nice grass you can walk into a nice Lush
Turf and then there's a a little ramp so
your wheels don't pull the [__] grass
up every time so detailed yeah and there
used to be like a big ass Internet cord
that was like randomly sprawled
throughout the thing but that's mounted
to the wall now this is a this corner
used to get Beat to Death you guys have
seen it in videos where it's the
drywalls constantly chipping so now
that's protected so Nick can back into
it as much as he wants it's fine we got
a little by the plane graphic which is
like a spin-off of our careful boys logo
hey let us know in the comments if you
guys want that in merch
War there's a basos with the boys which
was made specifically for Nick cuz
that's his uh I love it that's his
wholeo kiss kissing guys kissing guys my
my friends we have this um we have this
Jason chenny thing right here that's
that says a tribute for everyone in the
comments who keeps saying day 45 of
Anthony not releasing the shirt for
purchase the confusion cuz the fans
really want the shirt and it's nice to
see Jason
victims this is our snacks rack which is
now uh a much better shelf behind this I
fixed the holes in the doors too cuz
there used to be tons of holes in the
actual double doors behind this that I
CED that yeah I didn't know what that
was yeah they're patched up now but uh
yeah this is our snack rack uh all the
stuff that we get for sponsors and stuff
you can just put right here on the right
I put like the lawn thing um this is the
gentleman's area the smoking Lounge the
whatever you have it the um we got a
roulette table right here and underneath
it is craps which is kind of a throwback
to when we went to Vegas and shot at the
Trump Tower oh yeah and we tried to uh
play craps for a little bit and lost a
ton of money in record time don't pull
it off the world that's that stays up
really it might fall off sorry that's
kind of cool cuz that's like our
childhood era yeah kids these days don't
even know what the [__] that is nobody
knows what that is up on that [__]
that's why I needed to touch it this is
a basically um I wanted to make kind of
like a Town Square looking like uh sort
of just like a platformy thing that you
can actually sit on and you can actually
stand up there it's bolted to the wall
wow it's like a Hanging Gardens thing
with plants and stuff we got the careful
boys thing and then this thing was kind
of the thing that I was unsure of the
most cuz I really wanted the look of
like I've never seen like a pool table
mounted on a wall I thought it looks
yeah I thought it be a pretty unique
like thing and it kind of I don't know
it just feels like us so I just chopped
the whole base out and then uh and then
put these mounts on it and they're like
rated for 500 lb so this is not going to
fall off and this is probably the most
important thing is we've never had a
place to put the uh the plaques they're
always just sitting in a stack in the
corner so it's nice to actually see this
stuff and then down there is a school
paper of Bart and Joe from uh from their
high
school they wrote about us we are the
YouTubers this is
a they WR
up it's old this couch is is a freaking
steel like I didn't think I would be
able to get one this nice but it I got
this couch for basically 200 bucks from
a dude who needed to move out of the Poo
right away steal of a deal man I took a
photo of the Poo I was like hey check it
out that's why couch yeah so this is uh
the story of Bart hiding in the Ethan
Allen grandfather clock as shown in AI
form and then that's the literal form so
you have the ethnic doll Asian boy
inside the
yeah cuz bar was getting his ass beat
from his dad he had to hide and then
here we have the 13 in
September uh the shirt is up here and
then the old enough for kisses graphic
is right there you can get that shirt
but this one is not available yet I
don't know if you even want
it and then the K arcade we got the the
care I like I like how kjas is respect
all fear none and we're fear everybody
we should change this we should change
this out what if one day we just change
all the decals and everything so yeah
you can play this or or if you if you
want you can play the believe all women
game I like that one oh yeah the rug the
JK rug that uh our homie made for us and
everything that that started it all
that's the that's probably the single
most important thing here is literally
the the foundation of all this is the
uncle CH and Uncle Sam Museum This was
meant to be a Nick's Jiu-Jitsu Podium
that I was building and then uh instead
we we're just going to use it as like a
a merch display if you want a piece of
JK hisory merchlabs
docomo so most people remember this
doughnut being behind Barton Nick's head
for freaking years I didn't want to
throw it out so instead we just put it
around the thermostat yep it's kind of
cold it's 65 Dees right
now oh yeah Bart's painting's up here
now so uh Bart's unfinished yeah Sun guy
for people that for people that missed
seeing the sun guy I mean now it's
always going to be here the funniest
thing is he's he he's not even finished
with it and he hung it up for years for
years all right so this wall is here
basically to um so that we can have a
little private area for the kitchenet uh
you can roll it in and out it's
connected to the Shelf this is genius
right here this is the September 13
Jersey and back here is basically
Steve's room it's like his Colts themed
uh kitchenet because he's always coming
back here to make drinks and stuff with
Anthony but now it's a place to chill
and if we have guests that have a guest
and they need to like hang somewhere
they can always hang back here uh super
convenient super chill very thoughtful
we should show up before and after of
garbage and garbage
out garbage in garbage out garbage in
garbage out yeah plus then if there's a
game on or something or a fight then
Nick or or Steve could just put it on
this TV and like like watch your ear
it's connected yeah they don't have to
like rush to the bar oh that's the
classic uh just kidy news thing that
we've never been able to put up anywhere
but now it lives here it's always going
to be in the shot uh straight through
the hall bar Drum Set uh the fridge is
now free of expired uh
Dairy that's good oh man I have I
recorded so many uh so many videos of me
and smack were were competing to find
the oldest product what was the oldest I
think like 10 years or some [__] dude it
was mad there's one [__] like ezema
lotion it was like a like a creamer or
something it was like something nasty oh
yeah so there used to be like three
tables back here to consolidate it all
we um we disassembled disassembled one
of them and used the top and used the uh
shelves as the base and now this is uh
connected to the uh studs in the wall
when you guys think of this stuff like
you guys just brainstorm like you guys
just know what to do like oh we should
put the shelves back here so it could
double as storage and like how do you
even know to like dismantle furniture
and then like almost like re build
reconstruct the furniture how do you
know how to do that I think we just it's
just like decluttering like oh there's
three tables it doesn't realistically
need that many and storage wise I
because I've been here so long I kind of
see who really uses anything so I'm like
oh I mean if stuff like that's there it
won't be that like you won't be going in
there too often so it's like this is one
of the old the remnants that stayed this
couch kept this one here the worst couch
in the world I didn't even notice oh
yeah if you look on the other side here
these are all the metal signs that used
to be up randomly around the walls but
now it just kind of decorates the it's
funny because that was our attempt to
making it look like industrial and
vintage that was our attempt it's so
[__] whack it does look cool like
this like kind of cted together yeah so
this haul I know you can usually just
see it from in on camera and it's kind
of just like an afterthought but then it
would be cool if it looked a little more
like what's back there there you I'll
show you guys what's back
here [__] it's very childhood like 9s
kid
dreams and then the baby photos are all
on this side now yeah cuz we're kids we
saved the parts uh little bumblebee so
that it wouldn't get painted over yeah
this is Mitchell in's uh Game of Thrones
chair that he gave us that we used for
Hot Seat the mayor it got a nice little
respray because it was worn out from all
the butts that's been on it made by the
mayor of monter park that's a Bobby Lee
painting right there yeah Bobby Lee
original I don't know what he did but he
did something just made this a little
bit like
cooler uh the oh look at the bathroom so
the bathroom is kind of it's not smack
did a really good job just kind of
organizing everything in here it used to
just be a metal rack with like tons of
random crap everywhere but it's a little
bit uh nicer now there's a mirror here
yeah there's just like a little bonus
mirror I think that was an extra one
that was laying around that we just
wanted to use see it's very thoughtful
everything like people get ready guitar
right here it's not even
mine it's such a good feeling man it's
such a good feeling yeah man I think
that's about it other than that there's
convenient things like little um
electrical things everywhere so you can
actually have access to Ports so it's
not it looks good and it's functional
yeah I try to hide wires as everywhere I
could so that like even this thing like
wired all the way around but then that
way it just like looks neater you got a
good brain thanks man so as you can see
we have all new chairs six of them right
here these are from wellne Life they're
super comfortable highly adjustable um
you can be a lazy dude and recline them
or when we need to be perked up you can
have them uh straightforward super cool
well New Life uh was able to get these
to us in time for this shoot really
awesome chairs man and Steve didn't even
notice he was sitting in it for the
longest time dude that's Nikki would
like die laughing right now because
that's the most mean thing ever but yeah
I sat in this chair and then I was like
wait he's like yeah we got these new
chairs and I was like what the
[__] dude they're helic Che these out
yeah if you guys are interested in these
chairs we can uh we can uh let you know
more about them just
DMS keep and the best thing is these
wheels if you look at these wheels these
are like uh rollerblader Wheels they're
super quiet like really smooth yeah hey
look how fast I can spin
this hey K catch up catch up no catch
how quick catch how quick I'm moving no
that's that's what I was doing you're
not moving that fast c can look how
quick I move my
leg oh [__] dude all right got a [__]
break man oh yeah so wherever this guy
is now James Rulo uh hopefully you see
this this get get back to you but thanks
for all the years of uh of making those
compilations for JK news uh and getting
more views than the actual
videos we just the fans have always
talked about James Rulo even to this day
so we just want to make sure that uh
that wherever you are that you know that
you're remembered yeah hopefully it's
representative of of everything that the
JK audience now uh resonates with so uh
there's so much signature stuff that was
made only because of the audience and
only because of the DMS and the messages
and the comments and everything so uh
thank you for contributing to how this
place looks we love you Ryan love you we
love
you without you we would all be
unemployed I'm willing to give all my
money to Ryan yeah we're going to give
our my J purse you want to invest you
want to invest in me yeah
[Music]
dude
PA
[Music]